part 3 of our bundesliga trilogy after
hoeneß and watzke comes
probably the most successful german
player advisor to volker struth
who in 2014 would be find i had three
or four clients on the pitch
including big and götze and higher des
and a few others representing over 100
different players  and of course understands
the sports business again
from a different perspective
and he himself made a donation career
from the cologne merchandise
entrepreneur from the distributor who made
villingen dilling, so to speak,
in cologne all of a sudden thanks to the
reiner calmund slipped into the player consultant business
is a very later career
and now  since the big wheels are turning
how all that could happen that would
now be a
warm welcome to the podcast with volker struth volker guilt I
feel honored in the order
thank
you so much tell me a bit you were
n’t actually born at all as a
player’s advisor it’s not football either
you're actually an entrepreneur and
finished the song but
his background is interesting because you're
really a salesman with a heart and hate
somehow made events tells he
knows where I'm from because I'm a
footballer but I wasn't good enough
to get to where the boys are
today consultant game
that's why soccer has always been my
life my passion
and yes then I realized very early on that
I
wouldn't get rich enough at least by playing soccer not to do anything
else or to learn whether
I did all kinds of jobs after my apprenticeship as a carpenter for a
few years
then retrained as an
industrial clerk and founded my first company at the age of 27 it
was actually a paper company
i carried boxes of copying paper into various
offices and the
potato dealer used to bring the
potato sacks so
i went to the
industrial areas with my copying paper and sold them
and beyond  is  then there was a big
sample it was allowed to trade
he added advertising material and
merchandising products
i did insolvency and then a
good 15 years ago i
changed the industry completely i am a
player consultant but you were
already relatively successful back then when you wrote
the book  it's charred
mostly it's just going through the
media and in the list of the best so you
said you had already made your first million
before you started in
sports that was already possible through
these events and merchandise products
thank god i already
had them  because in the business I
'm in today, there's so much pressure today,
even more than 15 years ago when I
started, but of course
my I'll say capital
that I'd already earned back then gave me a
lot of rest and a lot of pressure
with the players I'm
accompanying today yes, how should I describe it
not necessarily on the on the on  to be dependent on the
next transfer or on a
contract extension or something like that
was
reassuring i mean i founded my first company at the age of 27
and with her i was already 41
then switched to the other industry
so i wasn’t just a few  years was
on the road for 14 years with my office
supplies slash merchandising
and event in cologne there were still meetings
that is a very special story
about that exists it owns that was is
a very special story is
also in the book back to the beginning
i had merchandising rights to the
or licenses at the munich
oktoberfest
and that's how we were there for the
opening
in munich and we
noticed that
from morning to night they played kölsche
songs viva colonia superjeile
zick as they were all called and is that
somehow he's often in my life  the
case arose for a very short
moment which music also belongs to
people from cologne  seen and met oh
that's something you can do in cologne too
and if an idea got
stuck
somewhere in my life then i've usually implemented it in my life
and so it was also
a huge success with the oktoberfest in cologne
over many years then there will still be a
role yes there is still i am
no longer active myself but it is
still there then
1000 people will come i think the
tent has a capacity of
three and a half thousand people that works
over three weekends yes only one week
so that's a roof that can't be
compared to the one with the munich
oktoberfest so that's a big
marquee and then there's
a bit of a party on the weekend that it
was a great success in phases there was
definitely that  0 3 liter beer mugs the
people i mean that there is no
art gallery in cologne costumes yes we
all wore either dirndls or
lederhosen and there wasn't one
bavarian band or there is a
bavarian band but there are also music groups
from cologne that perform highlight
are they bring it they are
very well known here in cologne they perform every
year and every evening so great
story here 21 from the main events true
and then  Merchandise products that also
sounds very broad there you saw few
ideas somehow and then
imported to cologne more or less
exactly i come from cologne there is something
in cologne at the cologne carnival
but here there are over 100
carnival societies
carnival clubs and you can see that
a respective one also goes to
which club it belongs to so blue has a
white swan or and green and white only
then red white man you get
a bit of each other or
kept apart but in cologne
over a million people still celebrate
carnival and I got me  at that time
i thought i need is for the people who are not involved
in the carnival and then i got
this  en so-called motto shows in the Cologne
carnival always invented a very
special word, but here you
can call it that, so the
moto scarf is a scarf on which is written
the respective carnival motto what the
Cologne carnival is every year
and under which it is the carnival  celebrates
under the motto that we had a scarf
printed and
people identify with it and that's how the cologne
motto seems to have come about i
had that in the other colognes in the other strongholds in germany i.e.
in mainz in düsseldorf i'm then it
happened  did today so being
close to my merchandising also had a
lot to do with licenses and ideas
yes i have tried again and again
to do that in
my shop today somewhere to stand out from the market
yes so to buy the red and white scarf
somewhere
that was now  not the great art, yes,
and then
selling it en masse, but selling a scarf  fen by saying there is
a story somewhere behind yes and with
the cologne motto look at what happened back then but
also so that after a certain time we
grabbed this one part of a large part of the proceeds and the renovation of cologne schools i got
the car drives 2006  for the world cup
you can probably remember most of
them I was completely
alone but of course I didn’t have them
produced in
2006 but much earlier and
from then on they were sold or put on the
market and yes that was something like
that  driving the car to the world cup was
your best product, so to speak, in
terms of sales
it was one of many products but
not the best so i
also went through this year i of
course not only
made fun of this motto but i then
also hundreds of companies or
i think thousands of companies in
germany are supplied with charles
and with all of them  n possible
merchandising products yes that was what we
had at the time of the
2006 world cup we still had many shops easily
more than 100 employees we had
halls full of
merchandising products that i can
remember when i was in the 80s
or 90s or  even at the beginning of 2000
i went to the football stadiums there
were a few people with
a scarf standing there if you walked into a
football stadium today take a look before the
game well depending on how if it's
a club the anthem has that we
have most of them then arise there
the whole stadium is
full of these letters that means that
the product the merchandising product
that she has already developed and
that's why i think even if i hadn't
switched to this branch
i would be i'm in poverty i would
n't have fallen for
something  i thought about it at borussia dortmund
, 25 years ago, a converted
french fries car was bought in front of the stadium and the art
od  he buy scarves if you are in
front of the stadium today it is in dortmund there
is a department store there it is a
real department store there you need
an hour and a half if you
walk through it to look at all the products what merchandising there is
today too  yes that was
my business yes of course in the run-
up also the the office supplies company also
had quite a lot of customers yes came in
canada and then came pure calmund
not but many years before
I knew what do you have var partner and i
know i know i can  I
still played football as a teenager and
didn't recognize pure calmund
but we knew each other from hello
and good day we had met
personally and got to know kalli again
or met again when
we
2004 slash 2005 I don't
remember exactly
the
world cup took place here in cologne the cologne
the city of cologne were one august one
so one  en location was
uploaded and the calibra nrw representative and so
saw us again and again in various working groups
and got
closer to us and
found kalibers then often
chatted a lot with one with a lunch and a
confusing dinner
and then developed more and
at some point  Reiner calmund joined
my company
as a representative. I hired him as a
representative and then
also
founded a marketing agency during the sports phase
and
served the purpose
that we marketed the German sports university
, so I
was somehow always fascinated back then
from the german sports university the advancement of
a sometimes there are
trained sports teachers or people
who are a bit marketing-wise
on the way but there are
improbably many interesting
scientific institutes within
the german sports university and the
content from them they have  With my agency I carried
the stars spots totally into the
economy and of course
also did business with it and
earned money with it so if you have
seen the temple of the German Sports University on many a water bottle
or see it says
sports-scientifically tested then that was
our story summer
and
then of course we started because we were through the 2006 world cup
in germany we have the
entire topic of
public viewing
i.e. gastronomy fan articles we accompanied everything that went
with it
and based on our experiences if you are of
course also interested in the countries
then in the
after  who have organized various tournaments
, among other things, austria
austria switzerland was the
european championship in 2008 and i got a job as a
consultant and that was the
second business area of my sports marke
ing otherwise the candidate will be in tow y
s i
can take a tow truck or calli watch
as you wish and
then
my long-term
partner from my old
agency, who was already in the business
, came to me at the time
and asked me to contact
calais then gave it to the nazis and then gave a
few talks and then
sometimes we totally packed the field player advice
under the umbrella of sports
calli accompanied that a bit where
a few months after we
started it the academically
arrived called back to your question i was
just there for two days with my family on
vacation in mallorca  and the
caliph like that has to talk to you
commissar mallorca
and then he was actually there for three
days and these three days
only dealt with that
and he also only
dealt with persuading
me to do it without any motivation of his own he
wasn't involved
just wanted something for you yes you
really have to that is difficult to convey what
is really
yes, kalli got his representatives over
the years from me or from
us
and stuff like that from the company
but he never benefited from it in any way
that wasn't
his ulterior motive at all
by the way calli has it in his  I
always acted like that throughout my life without
thinking too much about myself, but rather about
the other modules. It
is clear to me that Kalli always wanted to
talk about the economic advantage of the
other everyday approach to earning email with his life
like with the ones with your scarves
and driving a car and a coup made your
paper and an oktoberfest et
cetera you are made for it and
i am sure that you will be successful with
it and it started then
you have it when i really
I also understood that as a
market entry as a sweet spot that caught
the generation of highly talented
young footballers at that time that e
r didn't start out with well-known names,
but back then it was a
generation that you didn't know back then like 19 20 you
didn't know but further
annoyed the same day if you with the
hybrid are as if I was one of them that
's because the sweet spot is the low one
to find houses and say okay something
is happening here in german football it
comes back to these young people who
are looking for two things so in
2007 when i started
in this industry two
very big differences to today more of
a difference is just like you
you describe there was already
a major customer a larger pool of
talented players
the second but the much more important
reason is there were not as many player
consultants as today so the cake was
divided up differently today there are more
player consultants than professional footballers so
my story is like that  some people also describe it
as a fairy tale today i
don't want to rule it out that's
not possible but  in any case, it's
very, very difficult to repeat so
getting back into this business today with the mass of consultants and on the
other hand you have to we
're in a phase right now where there aren't
quite as many talents as there are german
talents  like that was the case 15 years ago
but there are intervals that can
change again in three or four years
that has always been the case over the years
i was lucky that
i entered this business at a
time as a drop  out there a
lot of 17 18 year old highly talented
guys still left without advice and that
was then also his the ticket
direct to somehow get big names later
on so you think i
had early on we will do that in a
whole a special example of
benedikt höwede marcel  hossa was my first
player if we take the example bendikt
if you are the door it is you
shouldn't imagine that the
mountain if you di  e tür wird is
waiting for me with his family, yes,
but there were
definitely a whole lot of other consultants who
were interested
in working with the family, but that
was all a bit more
manageable and, above all, the
decisive thing  point benedict about
that was 18 years old when we
started working together that's
no longer conceivable
today the boys are already addressed
at 13 14 which I don't have he
but we have a minimum age that
's 16 with an absolute  with the exception of
talent you can also phone the parents
when the boy is 15 but
i don’t believe in marching
into the office of a sports director with a 13-year-old
and
our well i’m the
advisor here that must also be forbidden
we know that then anyway that
you start something like that i mean with
many company start-ups i can
imagine my web  site and
then it slowly starts when you buy
you somehow seem to buy and see it
but at your there it's about a
person always has to have that borders the market
that has calories as a consultant from
football and knows the industry a
bit from the  far away or is it
just around but not itself what
no consultant at the time and then
you don't say anything or gave
his intro or you give the
phone number says people know
people he just tried to get
started these are several would say
about it  jump before you then
really work together with a player the
first thing to know is that there is
someone who plays football well that is
called
buying it but a lot of people do it and play English
or youngsters from minus
Bayer Leverkusen or from Schalke 04 in the
example  so to stay
he plays and that in the morning at 11 o'clock
then we assume from the 200
spectators it used to be 20 and today it is  out of
200 spectators 100 who are the consultant or
scout
that means you don't have to be jesus
to scout an 18-year-old
benedikt höwedes out of the fact that if he
knows a little bit about football
now comes the second hurdle you
have to have a phone number from
with the boy or with my parents
it was always the case that i really liked
talking to the parents or the first conversation with the parents has to
be made of it
then you have to get him on
the phone in the phone call it has to be so good that
you can get an appointment  that's what everyone
else wants, too,
and when you have the appointment,
you always have to know you won't
be the only one, let me say like a
patch or something, who gets the opportunity
to introduce himself as a person
or as a company with his concept
with his  philosophy with his
thoughts and everything that goes with it yes
you have to be good at the table you have to be the
player and then especially with young
players  above all the family
because they often still bear
the responsibilities but then there is
who else listens then 17 18 year old boy
who walks normally when it is normal but the
parents are also right so much more
life experience have much much better
feeling for  a situation like that
you definitely have to convince this collective
family
and then
yes you have if you then i would
say go home after such an appointment
these three four
hurdles for which i just
described you jumped them but
that means  yes still not that even
get the approval but if you if
you then of course get the
work as on but before that i want to
describe how difficult it
is to generate a player for yourself it
is a totally brutal competition
but i mean  just at the beginning it was
n't there yet references today
you're running the appointment rheine everyone knows
or you can quickly say i
've got it  e here are the biggest names in the
business, which of course is a huge
advantage, but back then there was
no reference here in the sense of what happened
then, so the decisive sentences were
do you think the pitch was convincing at the time with the height
of the family from what believes
i think  I'm honestly a with
certainty which is not a disadvantage in the
phone call and as I said it has to
be able to make phone calls first but
if you were in the phone call in
2007 2008 it was still there
I can still pretty
much well it wasn't like that  long ago left in
2004 bayer leverkusen
was there in a very
crucial position for 27 years and
also helped shape this football business,
you have to say, and it stuck in many
people's minds and
believes vater höhe that was actually
it, so i talked about it  the fact that i have
pure calmund as a kind of companion
advisor by my side i
think that was definitely not
a disadvantage  Nice argument but
that alone is of course no longer enough
because the calendar was not there for these
appointments, at least not for the first
interviews, if
it was later with us or
if it had already developed in that
direction, then the career
also came along and  I once said that in
my case it was like that but very very
rarely I am asked this question very
often how did you manage it back
then I am here you are right
I was never a professional soccer player so I was
not known at all in this soccer scene
my name the
man just didn't know me and yes
but how many people out there are
doing sales or
will try to sell to a customer i'll
say that right now trying
to get to a customer and
are in an extreme competition yes
why  there are successful and
less successful ones that has
to do with components that in my
opinion start with
diligence  after that comes empathy yes you need a
very specific toolbox
and to be successful in sales
you don't have to learn you either
have it or you don't have it that
's clearly my attitude so i'm
starting in a competition in
a highly competitive industry
become successful and why that is the
case, yes, i always describe it with
exactly those qualities that i just mentioned
, but there are also people
out there in many, many other industries
who will know what i am talking about, yes,
many, many entrepreneurs can
understand that a bit  that's the
reason why there are successful ones and
less we know that the
mechanics so if you get a
player saying if he signs
if he becomes his client, so to speak, then
you earn as a consultant, at least
externally, it's always the blanket
statement ten percent  at his
annual salary you get from  club and
, mind you, as for his
consulting services, that allows
the player to do it himself
but allows you to say that the
club only has to pay then
that is a very simple construct
you give except that I don’t
sign anything, so I don’t have any
contracts if mine  players
i don't do that and otherwise the piece is
explained we usually earn ten
percent of a player's annual salary
that the club i'll say has it in
its budget and then sometimes pays the player's advisor
like we do in
many other sectors euroshop just
last friday  talked to
someone from the show industry and
even opened my mouth when he
said to me, in our industry
the agents get 20 percent in america, for
example, the sports agents earn
significantly more money than we do i
can't even justify earn a
lot of money enough  money but
still injected again relativi  eren that one
always thinks that the players' advisor in
football gets money for the fact that he,
let's say, accompanies a business
and carries out mediation yes that's the case
in many industries too only with us
before time gladly and frequently discussed
and in the second component the
sometimes come is with the transfers
themselves so transfer made because
you transfer fees or even if
there is no more transfer then there is
still money in hand there is still
the chance to
earn money there is also yes there is
there is transfer participation and there are
numbers there is everything that is there for
players and there is also that for consultants
it always depends on what
position you are in with
such a change yes that’s the price
it’s always been determined like that since the
middle ages  mr price is
always based on supply and demand and
if you want a player in a very
good contract
constellation then you can  three other
clubs also have it, then of course that’s
a good negotiating position, that’s also
the case in many, many other
areas too, what is
the average, so to speak, so in a
digital is let’s do the math, let’s see what it
costs to win a customer and then
what  you can earn money with the customer based on
his or her durability, i.e.
the value between seconds what is
a player like that in Germany
always says he had only found a Bundesliga
game can’t
generalize so of course that has
something to do with the performance of the
player  to do yes with the market is
a player yes and above all momentum
to do there are players who have advised in the
last 15 years who are
perhaps organically known to most of his listeners
but have made
very good money with them because that means
we are talking about  five million c very well,
you can't generalize that
it happens every year
salary of the players but then in relation to the market value
i would just explain
there are players who
are not so well known to the public of course in
football business it is known yes but like that
i have had average
bundesliga players with whom we made very
good money  because we just timed
the momentum and not so
consciously but it was
like that I'll give you an example if a
player is
very
well ambivalent in his performances
so you have a player who is during
his and that please please don't be
wrong what will happen  not manipulated yes he
is an average player during his contract period
and
strangely enough the more so that the end of the
contract is approaching yes he
suddenly topped and performed and played a
giant yes yes
then you suddenly have one with this player who is
actually only considered to be an average
Bundesliga player
negotiating position yes he has a good
year of  only has a short
contract period and 23 other clubs
are taking notice of him and
that of course affects these players
the very good
negotiating position there is of course
the other side of the coin and that
is very often forgotten in my line of work
we also have players and
every advisor has that yes then you will be happy at the
end of a transfer period if the
top note club has to be awarded
a topic which, by the way, will now increase due to corona
we will
have
significantly more unemployed players in the future
than before yes that will come the
scissors  diverges these absolute
top players they will have in the market
but the average player and they
will in the next 12 years
do not panic there will be quite a
few who will or
will be more unemployed in the
future wanted clubs can no
longer afford either  want a big crater
that for example yes because
always  more for internationalization, so
we have more and more players
from abroad, although I also
advise players from abroad, so it
's not that I only support German
players now, the focus of our
portfolio is German, but we have
that, that's also in the  nowadays it's
a must that you look
nationwide and see that you then let me say
on the other markets one
or the other player or one or the
other transfer generates one or the other
entrepreneurial question with this
business model
how big is your company currently there
you can see  how you get in here
is very interesting we're
just looking right on the rhine so it's
an agency in the end there's an
agency model logically you have
around 25 30 people who work
and annual sales then it's kind of like
15 20 years old interested students so
we're 24  employees and
currently look after almost 80 players. I
have a  i started to
get into this business back
then, i always wanted to make
sure that i break away from the market
when i started, there was this
classic player advisor, like there
is still very often today, maybe one on the
phone somewhere
part-time worker yes then meets
with his players and with his
with with clubs and some hotels
or restaurants also has a
small office somewhere that was the classic yes
and as I said there are
still quite a lot of I
said directly  once you have built this up as a
company i want to
stand out from this market that is
also one of the reasons why we have been successful for so
many years that means
company yes to company means
file this business of the
player consultant always in two pillars
one is the core business  the
core business is soccer players in a timely and performance-oriented manner that is in line with the
market
best to arrange te employment contracts then or
i would say with the addition that they play football
happily in the right place at the right time
then you have
done everything right so that others that
is so these these peripherals these are
the services we provide
must provide services it means we
try to relieve the player
as much as possible so that he
can concentrate on his
job playing football and of course we also try
to make it better with our possibilities the better he is
some will now say deserves the
study more  money he was right
so how can
you do that you can do that by having an
apparatus in which video analyzes are
created so we talk to
the player about cutting his game
scenes that
we have an inside service there are
three employees the ops of
changing tires now in winter it
starts again if the tires change  hselt is whether
it’s moving house, going to the authorities
, whether it doesn’t matter what,
booking a holiday trip et cetera,
it’s accompanied by my back office staff
, we have a
nutritionist who analyzes the player
and doesn’t just
eat less pasta and lots of
rolls  blood results from bernard are
obtained nutritional analysis makes we have
a large network of doctors
physiotherapists
we have people working for us who
take care of this whole social the whole
social media issue we have in the
press spokesman for tax consultants lawyers
everything that goes with a
company like ours
everything is covered that
a player may need at some point
and what he will use of
it he has to decide for himself at the end of the day
so I don't
go there and and and follow running players with a
wooden spoon if he doesn't follow
along  our nutritionist meets
most m  oh do it on your own or i
can't force a player to do it
with our mental coach
in our house you can also call it
by name
friedhelm funkel's wife is not that unknown either she
runs our foundation
but she is also
mental coaching for  active and
not to force the academic players
i just want to have as many offers as possible
that i
can give the players
how relaxed they have to decide for themselves
but I had to introduce it roughly that
’s how this company is structured here
and then of course with all  a lot of guys
who run around scouting and scouting
is what i just explained then of
course they have to know when
new talent will be around somewhere we
have to be there because that is also an aspect that is
very important in our business
speed speed here
it's really about speed and
I always love the saying from
the calligraphic calli, the quick f  the slow ones
don't eat the big ones the small
ones even if you're bigger so fast
and big is of course the best thing that can
happen to her but i mean i
would ask you if she hinted at a book it
was also said
it was mentioned so sales figures are already there
so there are  pay one out
and say yes we bet we bet
you can follow that too so
i won’t tell you gaia exactly you
can follow that too but we
already make sales in the two-digit
million range if a book
i think something like that by now a bigger
20  millions in
but don't leave the years there too
that's a big
year so that's ok you have to be very
clear than making 20 million sales with
commissions a big year
i want to hold on to
tears but i've got it  Yes, just
explained that such a company also costs
money, of course, it was
several millions every year, of course, and
fixed  en cost so you can also chef
tigger good people and the people who
are better than me in many areas and
that's why they also earn good
money and yes, well I don't even have
that in the sense of before or greedy
because of one thing  who also found a book that
surprised you. in the start-up
world you know founders who try
to sell the company after a few years
and you had that as an offer
to sell the company a few years ago, i
think you said
somehow you would have  got a lot
more than in the book i
seem to remember you
bid 65 million pounds for the
agency you didn't do it exactly because
that's easy
i think i make good money in this
business yes and if you say it
if you can if you can always  if you keep
the bleisch watch on and don't
lose yourself in the ground under your feet
and just keep going and
tempted to try to get a little
better ma  n already
earn enough money in this business if you sell to such an
investor then
at least in my business 1 he
wants me to stay with my
people and doesn’t need to sell
so that’s a bit different in our business
with so many stars
with so many founders who quickly sell a patent
or a product or something
here is something different here with us
that if you if you
sell this company to an investor
you can and must this investor
insist that the cow so the  the team
around me stays on board and the industry is
not for sale
i would sell if i said yes and
now i can lay my head somewhere
nice in the straw was somewhere
but i wouldn't want that either
, i want to remain my own
boss and  then you have to be on the road in
this business for a few more years
, you can internationalize your own business
so i have
yes already said in the preliminary talk one thing
that surprises me is that this is not yet
the case he says but is wrong you
have the international client in the
end in the portfolio of course customers in the
sense of club anyway i mean your
probably most valuable player toni
kroos plays for madrid  somehow timo
werner in london and if that
's clear but also again
foreign players it's difficult
it's more difficult the
other languages other cultures there
is also the market for playe
advisors and i think
it has a lot to do with that  whet
so i just described it
let's go back into the area
you have now got the phone number
you have with a family member
you managed to get an appointment
and then you sit with
this family at the table like this and now
you are  the French but if it ever comes
to the language I have an
employee with me who will save me  r rosa
speaks six languages,
that's of course a huge advantage
when you have a person with one
side who speaks so many languages,
but nevertheless i
don't speak their native language and i'm
the player's reference person
that has in many many cases
because yes
it was enough so the talks or
others but so good that you said
no with with with with with the with the with the with the with the with the with the with the with the
the then I’ll say
the example of whether americano
diddy diddy the parents and the french
is today both
the parents and  and in the rosa file they
already knew each other from the leipzig days
that was of course an
additional connection the language is
something very very important but there is
the topic of culture there is the topic of
tradition and you need it if you can
if you can  to join such a
table you need one you have to
create a trust bonus a trust relationship and that
is natural  if you found the native language
of such a player speaks it
's a bit easier than if
you don't speak it yes
but nonetheless we have some
players are not only because your grandfather
is mecano yes is yes we look after but
definitely he played in leipzig the boy we
do we have a player at red bull salzburg
with a camera we also have
austrian players we have
swiss players everything we are already
we've been making sure that we
've been internationalizing that for years yes so
what are the success factors otherwise in
demand from these
european legends as a football club
look at it then there is always it can
always fall in the evening when the really big
money is called there is a pini
zahavi what is his name, i think i call it
somehow comes or mino raiola the sports press has been looking for
years and think
okay now it’s about the money and
all of a sudden these guys are back at the table
what could save the baltic sea
say  s knew the guys who
let them take care of them wear a
network that goes back years but i wouldn’t like it
now i hope that does
n’t seem too narrow-minded make it smaller
than some of the lame ones you just
said that is without a doubt mino
raiola is currently in  i think europe is the
greatest advisor because he has made
the the biggest transfers in the last three four years
and of
course also attracted attention with transfers
in which he in turn
participated well, yes, the story with the
pop bar back then from juventus turin to
manchester  united changed and the
rumor mill was where between 20 and 30
million
euros the mino
raiola that's madness is worn yes
but
that's difficult to convey the subject
has no doubt that's difficult to
convey but this player switched
to juventus at some point
and he's free
changed there and at
that time very, very many people wanted it
have clubs and then that's that, then in
this phase the consultant says okay, the
group should develop here, but
if at some point we're
worth a lot of money and are sold to a big
English club, like that
was the case, right?  sold to
a big club at all then
i would like to participate in it the man's
entrepreneur that's his right
if the market allows it can only
hope that the player also participates in this
transfer because that's
the important thing yes that's
a condition for me so i can
don't earn money from such a transfer
if the player doesn't earn money
from it that's not possible that's why
I hope and then I
also assume that the player will also participate well in
it so now this player comes to
box juventus turin
and changes two or three years  later
to humanity for i think 100
million euros and that then the player
and the advisor there 20 30 percent of the
pr  ovision of generating the transfer fee
that's difficult to
convey is a lot of money
but from a business point of view it's totally
normal just because it's just football
yes just because it's just football
then of course we have a very
special taste you have to tell this
story  always
look at
it from two sides but nevertheless i know that
our business
gives rise to a lot of emotions, especially when it comes to such
amounts and you have also
given up defending me against it is
you can't and as i said it is of
course also for the otto
Normally it was difficult to understand
but that's important to me again
when I take the thing that
transfers pop bar from Juventus Turin
to Manchester United. There's a
French player moving from
an Italian club to an
English club and you know where  the
most talked about was
this transfer in germany g  anz clear
again and again it's yes so put the word as the
next question it
annoys you a bit that you come to the
usa it's quite noticeable there
are suddenly super agents or
players' agents themselves stars so right
in the del the
musician singer their
kind of happy now rich paul also has
his super agent there is the press he
has become a glamor figure jaycee
the hip hop star is now also
on the road with a sports agency so to speak
then there is a smaller guy who has
kevin durant ready so in basketball he is
there too  has meanwhile become his own
brand and that's not so in
the already celebrated people in the scene
not at all that
the usa gets the otherwise landing
and here in germany it's
still a bit of the image of the eternal
child a vice that  partner
daimler he just explained so yes i
have never never in this at this
time with a child together  Nursing where even
16 17 year olds are still children somewhere
but now
it doesn't annoy me and that's also
something you have to say very clearly
here now too
so that you've experienced a lot of acceptance
even now when
the book has changed over the past few weeks  or when
the book came out four weeks ago
or five weeks ago
i received an unbelievable amount of
encouragement there are quite a lot of
people who say it's a great
story that you put there yes that's
it it comes from humble
backgrounds and then you're in
this too  business
water you are very successful
to this day and i explain it
all a bit in my book i get
a lot of encouragement here in our society too that has to be
said very clearly
br malten different mentality the
german has a different mentality  as
the ami of armida you are very clear
how you describe it you up to the pop star
i mean there were many years ago
a film that maybe you can
remember jerry maguire absolute
great that was just played by tom
cruise is there he plays the agent of
a soccer player and the five
oscars were american fairy tale yes and also
body my story would then
be
rated differently and  being
commented on a little more euphorically and being reported about it
i'm normal germany being a
woman germany and i live
and the people are just different here
and she's all a bit
more critical and the glass is more often half
empty than half full and
that's why it's a nuisance  also
lawyers popstar that may be yes
brad you also your players with his
investments so i earn now
that's what they earn that's super close
now we'll do something with the money so
also investment are you then also the contact
person or as via google
that you  you ask me the question it's very
important to say it mostly in life
i can't that people sometimes
clear about that if you ca
n't do most
things if you're lucky
enough to be able to do a few things well to very well then that's
enough so i have this attitude
which is just important and can
only give that to every entrepreneur you have to
look around the people  allows you around
who are significantly better in the areas for which
you hire them than
you have to be able to endure and now to come
back to your
question you are already investing in it
because I can't do that I
will advise myself in the area but you have to
people know this well and
you have to be good at making the right
recommendations but i
myself
have so much
knowledge of what you do from investment of what you do his
own vests are then somehow
very conservative stocks or was a
property so if i  further well
accompanied yes I will be well accompanied ok
you look at me as if you
want to know
you don't want to say want to say d  as know
so i absolutely i have an
absolute top professional with carsten
maschmeyer men are and yes and
at least have the knowledge that
many of my players
let you accompany them but they already knew
him form ok so you recognize that
now generally more than  in germany
because he is still very present with
tv and others on it a social
okay what is it you are friends and
dont ask about friends at all
so friends friends we like
each other yes we respect each other the word
friendship i can
imagine that it will go away at some point
developed but in such a way that now for many
years friends and and and
the closeness so that's no use if I
now accompany my husband my husband my assets
of someone that's my
friend but maybe not that
good in his field let me tell you  so
i prefer to let someone do it
who is very good in his field
and i like h  you just have to call if
you have
any idea about it, so references will come i think it was the other way around but again i knew i knew that many of my players have been working with carsten maschmeyer for many, many years
and i will
be there at some point  I went there
and decided to change
something
about it and carsten was informed about it or about it how it is like that
I mean you get
information in sales or in
business it always has to do with information
about christian information when you
get to know each other  we talked a lot about the fact that i
always gain players when they are 17
or 18 years old and then you start them
and stay, but many of our
players switched to us during their
careers as a professional and changed their advisor yes
and that happens when the
information generated so there is
someone
somewhere in my shop he is playing
football and he just has yes there is
a thought process city in his advice
in his management or as far as the topic
is concerned need the information of
course and then it also happens that
football players switch to us during their career
or switch back to us
per advice how are you  came up with the idea of
the book so i can r
ally only recommend it i read
t myself if you are interested it is defin
tely worth reading in a day i
great and that is also you c
n also say it was not written all by yours
lf  did someone
get it obviously really
hurt so the one on them was
probably better you can do it you
could write a book but
how did it come about so that was also a
bit of an idea to do brand
building like say okay i’ll pack them and book
market with them  after it's actually clear
if things go well that i'm the
market leader and i can then
use that or just have fun  say
i have to take part give something
back or how come out of the book
because he earns money you don't all
tourist book not a market leader
at least once in the area quite so
many books you can't write at all
writing is that until the
doctor comes along with it  market
leaders are addressed the title of the book describes my moves i wrote
the book for two
reasons one is i wanted to
tell my story yes i grew up with my grandmother in very simple
circumstances without
parents and
my grandmother is a person who has lived
through two world wars
my grandfather can,
after being in russian captivity for two years, has
to come home with one foot from the second world war my grandmother put
all three of her children under the
ground very early on, including
my mother
and yes
, as I said, in very humble
circumstances
The them  a well, as far as this
side of the medal is concerned, on the day
mario 2014 one of my players scored the decisive goal in the world cup final against brazil
but i pinched myself told me
the madness needs what there is now
33 guys open space and then has
my life was like that at that moment i
think i was happy but i was
also somewhere and
maybe it's hard to describe or
maybe it's possible and that's
why i thought at some point
you'd write a book about it
the second reason  is
that in my industry the
protagonists i.e. my competitors
viewers will all belong in one bag i
just want to start the
debate
that there are good and bad in my job just like
with cherries and doctors and in many
other professional
groups i wanted that  simply
telling people something doesn't always allow itself to be
misled by the cliché somewhere in a
corner  and don't believe everything
like it's often reported in the media
, but if you listen to
how the job of a reputable
professional player consultant works, there are
certainly
some black sheep in my industry and they also
ensure that we are united within this
industry  1 have an ugly reputation and
i
don't want to
appoint myself to be an acolyte here either and and and
say yes i'm the saint of
player consultants now there are a
lot of my competitors who do a
good job who make them look serious
professional and  I'm all very
happy to earn money that it will work out no one
close I won't say and we
all know that we earn good money
but the market wasn't invented,
this market came into being and
I describe everything in my book
so the two reasons are me  do you want to
tell a story and i want to
know how it actually looks behind
the scenes  n actually out and
you have to say that i found that as a
reader there you have more insights than
you expected at the beginning when i
saw it for the first time ok spielerberater
writes biography that ok that will be a lot
more but it’s not that’s
really then  you get a
lot of things that are tangible, very close to
you, things where you also used
controversies and one thing that i'll
talk about briefly because
it has to do with marketing and us or our industry is
now digital business, there was a
situation that one  Big agency Jung
von Matt also tried to set up a player
consulting agency from the
marketing process of the body that
means once the marketing mix is
in, we think you have to know that
hey then also tried to st
rt the agency by re
ruiting a player from the two test days
as your clients then and there it is
clearly said wowereit they have no idea at all
and that is marketing, it will be e.g  u
can talk relatively early
but it's with zelda
and raphael brinkert who did
it
now without attacking the guys personally
but
that was before the publication of a book
is extreme but it's
become even more extreme now i get it or  we
get at this agency and
i personally get at least one
application an application a day i.e.
people who write to me are
i want to become a player consultant or
i have followed your story and i and they
come from as many institutions as
possible and they are lawyers they
are  clearly also boys who have
just completed their studies these are people
who work in some advertising
agencies these are restaurateurs these are
failed athletes these are trainers
from the third federal league from other
sports you can’t
imagine what i can
do on my own in the book about it  publish about
the application and partly about the
love letters i get from
people who would like to get into this business
but that is a
business and i try to describe that in this
chapter if you
want to be successful in this business then
you either have something or you just don't have it so
you can't learn it
learning to be a player advisor is not possible
now of course there are
basic requirements but you
just explained this to chips
just saying the fact that today there are more
player advisors than professional footballers
he already says so much he
says so much so you have to be quick
and it's done  sometimes you also have to give the boy
sitting there in front of her with his family
arguments why he
should do it with you and not with one of the
3,000 others yes that's ne that's an
issue
i'm already so with this
umbrella term empathy and empathy  in
this case the actual toolbox
filled with properties that you
need for this picture for this business br
our partner visa is also a digital
payment technology company and
even more than that, definitely more
than a card, namely a network that
connects people that is the message you launched
last september
it’s about visa
adding value for every single user
want to create, for example, in the area of the visa
ebit card because it is now possi
le to vi
w every single trans
ction at any time by direct debiting from the linked account, not o
ly at the end of the month, so as a
ser you are much better able to ch
ck what you are doing  actually just
done and on a very large level
is the goal of visa companies
worldwide regions
to let the economy flourish there and who
could protect something better than
just one of the most successful
innovative most reliable
and pay the networks in the world all
nations to that  what we since so clear that
they generally so  planned also what you
offer under visa point d
[music]
other question also from the digital
area is finally this
transfermarkt.de really relevant for
you as always everyone says so this
website is only a company
digitally planned it already has
it  already you have many
years ago i ignored that i
'm honest but
now you look at
how are you one or the other
market value there arises
that the gentlemen will know how you how you
there how you there what you
decide and make it  which
criteria i don't know exactly now it's
noticeable that foreign
players often have a much higher market
value than our guys but also because
i don't know why but of course
it's now a platform
that people look at very clearly and
[music]
believe that i  that too so I'm there
myself now if I
now if someone player is
spoken to yes then i  I get the data in the
first step, I don't know how the younger
generation does it, but I
go to transfermarkt.de myself and see
how he still has a contract who advises him
under which market is he
managed, what krieglstein information is
out that's already there
digital central contact point for the goods
are you worried about the
bundesliga as such the question should be
asked because my observation is that
the bundesliga
could be difficult in the future the competition there is
also the premier league there the
big names change there there is the
attention in the end it's sport or
entertainment in the end a fight for
attention and if the
attention is increasingly in
england then it's not in germany and
then the money is always just
different and you also live very well
from the bundesliga from a well-funded
club  here
you don't think that somehow you can't
achieve that, but in general that the
Bundesliga  maybe next he will be left behind a
bit in the worst case
it will be like that what the bbl is in
basketball and the nba is then the
premier league and also quite nice bwl
but actually everyone is talking about lg i
do think that this that the future
[music]
for them  bundesliga is becoming more difficult
because the willingness of investors is
known is not given here
and in lodz they always talk about
england
i have to see what will happen
in italy in the next few years the
example will happen in france in the
next few years believes that it will
currently in
spain there are three and four clubs that can help each other
and even hand problems due to
corona, of course everything has
slipped a bit again, you have
to say that very clearly, so when i look at the
spanish league, things are going
much worse  in the
bundesliga and there also in the big clubs
you get something that
happened or is happening in barcelona  t but
that will calm down again at some point in the
next two years
investors are pushing into football other
countries will open their doors if
we stick with it and say let's
do it you have to accept it even if
the majority is and that's how i want it i
think  will the scissors
widen a little more
that i think it
's not set in stone that's in
my opinion that's a good thing
if there's a super league
a man sucks especially the
way that it is  because from one day to
the next all the people get their
heads banged
so I don’t believe in anything at all I
’m a total fan of the national leagues
also this competitive character these
qualification regulations like we
have I’m in favor of
relegation for promotion I’m in favor of
qualification of the  international
competition
so where's the rice i'm
totally against it i think but that's it
a kind of change
so there is a
shift in quality i do believe that
at some point in the next five to
ten years we will have a kind of european
league so that you have to come
back with the
competition criteria what kind of
league  if there are now twelve or fourteen
teams because of
me 16 and you don't get off
i found the number how it was
communicated and how it
should be set up as i understood
it i didn't think it was good so if you know
it yourself  the people from real madrid are quite
good because toni kroos made several
contracts and or you
made them and they were very loud
drivers of it and are smart i
would have read it in such a way that they
understood the spanish league will be left behind
anyway and  then suddenly they
no longer have a chance in european competition
because they are stuck in the spanish league
and there the money  no longer
get what you need and
to be able to remain European competition law that's
why they probably have
a super league now before it's too late,
no matter what the cost, so that we can get back into it so that we can still
connect to the strong
English clubs or or others
again i can i can
understand the thoughts of the clubs so i can understand from
this top club
but the way how fast it
went how it was communicated how that
again in the indi indi in the in the
in the football world out
I didn't think blowing was good and I also
think that at some point I'll just say there will be
a kind of European league but
that has to be dealt with in time.
All the protagonists have to sit at a table.
You have to think about where they are for. They
're like that  I now call this product the
elite league, the europa league,
so it's that we hold the bundesliga
and internationally that's s  oh well,
at some point there will be no Frisian
only if i could choose
i would leave it the way it is
now i will be allowed to choose
there will be a bundesliga or premier league
premiere the vision there will be an
italian premier league a
french premier league  there is the
champions league there is the euro
league there is the dfb cup there is relegation there are
also promotions that if that were
feasible and i was able to
decide today please let it go like this
because sometimes things
are pretty good like you  are who of all the
clubs and management with the darker
suitable is european now
almost everything so let's introduce you
negotiated with barcelona what negotiated with
madrid you know england i was
somehow particularly impressed in the
sense of business moderately particularly smart
particularly clever club management
yes  I just said I wrote the
book because there are
good and bad in our industry  There are real people, as is the case with
cherries and doctors, and
there are also a few there are
good and bad ones, there are also
special
ones, so over the years I have had
a serious, professional, rarely
friendly relationship with many, many club
representatives  our business doesn't and that's a
good thing that it doesn't exist
, we have too different interests for that,
but there are a lot of great
people who do great jobs and
there are also personalities that
I've just learned to appreciate over the years
also an example per es
ist von by florentino perez two
years ago but shortly before that i was
invited to breakfast or to
his breakfast and sat together for a few
hours and
probably a pleasant person with
a really great life story
behind it there is  quite a lot
so if the type is yes let's say the three of
us put the power center under  entrepreneur
already the decisive man there yes okay
okay what impressed you so because
he just has such an entrepreneurial appearance
also
entrepreneurial appearance but still
remains human yes well it
’s very personable we once
said to me im in Spanish of course
luck a little Spanish too  speaking
this is the toni kroos who is the century
transfer from real madrid and how
he explained it in a very loving way
but still entrepreneurial
dominant or said not because he
is the best player real madrid had under contract in the
club's history
it both  one of the
best but now let's get to the
fact that the entrepreneurial
price-performance ratio variety
cost 25 million, they've won the
champions league three times in a row
and toni has
a game share of a jump-start of well
over 80 percent almost 90 percent that
's something  he can't do anything better as an
entrepreneur  t happen and
so because such things happen but how he
then packs that is I like the one
probably likes there are other
apps on which he was hated the
starting eleven share is a constant
larger one even normally doesn't
look at you watch something else
turn when  you kind of
scout the starting XI share how share a
chance to score something you don't
know there's the logo there's a whole
lot of statistics that you
observe, so it used to be said that
a player is fast today a
player is measured on the first ten
meters  and on the first three meters on
the first 30 meters on the track etc.
speed is no longer just
speed so those are all values
ok at if you look at a pass rate
uel behavior running paths he talented that
ecause five years ago playe
s were a quarter of an hour after the game
as over  was experienced has you
ran for 12.7 kilometers or the
trainer comes to the kab  ine and says
to a woman the pig you
're not even ten kilometers there
is everything has also become a lot more informative due to digitization
also in our shop
what is your
decide for you then what do you
like to look at his  gps if
you really try to do
that a bit i think
speed is becoming more and more dominant in football
so you need a
certain basic speed and if you
don’t have that then you have to be
extremely good in other areas
last chapter which had several points of
contact with hamburg
uli  hoeneß said to me if
there was a club he was really afraid of
if it were managed differently that
would be hsv you were also involved with
hsv because mr kühne is part of
hsv and one of the
richest germans he approached you  whether you don't give a
little advice chancellor means
to kill woman again we were
still the first back then  league so still to
keep or bring it even higher that was
but if you didn't enjoy it
he realizes that it was fun at the beginning
but i had to realize very
quickly that it doesn't suit
what you just said about other
leagues in england  has every club
or pretty much every club had an
investor and this investor also
has an external consultant
because is not hired by the club
or many of them have that and
nothing else i have with or have
cooler and i decided for us i
think if a person  like klaus
michael kühne so much money in a
club pure point then it must also
be right
to bring in external consultants and
in that case he was just me and now it comes to
me it was directly assumed
that i made the decisions or the
recommendation or the information the
beautiful ones let me put it
directly with my wallet
and get the men  It's just wrong
because I took the money from the stage
, but I had an agreement with the bold ones, but
I was paid for
providing information and my opinion, such as
a network and not
definitely with oh and noisy own
players in the clubs a transfer me
good so that get half a million a
year and that's
just about booking and that's something that's
difficult to implement in Germany
there we are again not just described on the subject
with his cockpit
transfer or with a change with
us, things like that are
discussed and debated more vigorously
and it doesn’t go down at all
and then something like that is quickly
torn up and then something like that is
also difficult to represent and with
you have to make it very clear to
me i noticed for another three four months that
it was sometimes in business and sometimes a
company  men is not doing well i'm to
other clubs but then it was said it
's nice that you're coming to us but
now thought you're now more in the
north is set and so ironic
trace stands again had to do
it from people with whom i
has been in the business for years whether jörg
schmadtke or rudi völler or aki
watzke as they were all called we all
said young people don’t like
that they were right in
hindsight
but nonetheless and with uli
hoeneß saying to come back to the initial
question  hamburger sv would be
a club if it had different
structures if you came
into the club with a bit more quality and i
don't even want to say that there was always a
lack of quality but
the right people
never worked together at the right time it was
there is always something that doesn't fit
and i think that's the floor plan from the
last seven eight or almost ten
years
when the sic  h developed in the wrong
direction but you could
make it clear it's
a very big city with an
incredible amount of power behind it
look at the companies
and people
living in this city what kind of tradition the club
has  and i think even if
you klaus michael kühne
i would say if you had
acted differently and who if you had been
a bit smarter in one situation or another
then mr kühne's investment would definitely still have been there
without me  a few
years went on like that
because uli hoeness is said to be not that worried
there would be a lot to be made
of such a club but how do you see
the future can such clubs on
schalke or the big
ones are now all second division do you think that we will
be connected again  we can
swear they are
so getting off always costs money bidding
it's always always economical
yes huge hole to plug when that
Happened while I was still in a coma, of course it's
even harder now you have to see how
the whole thing goes on we'll play again in
front of 25% to watch and maybe play in
front of you but again this ghostly
backdrop how long does it go etc that
just has to look but up at the end
we also probably all agree that clubs
like schalke 04 hamburger sv or werder
premier belong to the bundesliga and i
hope that it will also happen to opel very soon
but if you are not sure
than i my probability
is not sure say where it is before
has been playing last for four years now
if you just left behind yes you can see that
sometimes and with every
year you stay in the second league
it gets more difficult because that that the
gap is getting bigger and bigger but
that is in the end you could
have said otherwise  he could
thank you very much for the order or for this interest but
i can't somehow do the rest of my business
together and then ha  When I
said that they now admitted
we gave back the mandate
or I have to be honest
then I decided three four months
after we started
I have a responsibility
towards my company and my players and that is not with each other
and  such a club
hurts you i would have when it was now in
hamburg 20 years of life hsv but
really become distant about the time i was
happy if it is but also
now please honor me but
let the church in the village also because it will definitely be
that it  there are top people
who accompany the clubs, that just has to
be clear, it's difficult now and
i think it's being done quite
well at the moment, but it just has to stay together
over a longer period of time in terms of
quality
in the sporting
management and and of
course you say hold on to your stomach
you have to give the whole thing time,
have been playing in the second division for four years
but nothing  nevertheless
you have to try to
allow a certain construct over a certain period of time
in hamburg things always started
very quickly and
sports director didn't fit the trainer
or
sports management didn't
fit the supervisory board what you
heard and read there is already a there
is  even such a pool of the most
diverse
interest groups is
not always very simple in terms of structure, such as
a club with supervisory boards and
all that there is that is also in cologne in
cologne, it is also not very easy to run
a club, that’s how it is at the moment
great here but
just running the club that's
anything but that I also want to
know the hamburgers at the moment I'm sure I'll have
a good look at what's going on
I would still have such
visions so what's to come in the
next few years continue like this
or do you still have it  what goals
for the for the agency for yourself
what what else experience so if wi  r if
we remain so successful as an agency
, we have done everything
right in the last few years. there is no
such thing as one
also the most difficult thing or do you get good at the
job than i suspect today
maybe no because the
age difference between you and the
player is also getting bigger and bigger so
how did you at the time
maybe 15 20 years older than the players
now
biologically logically  it
gets better over the years the problem
that is mathematically and biologically
only to be allowed is so i wo
n't get older and the age of a
professional soccer player so i'll get older and
the age of a professional soccer player
usually stays between 18 and 33
accordingly you're right but
never still fun and i
always have and will stick around
i listen  only then when two
criteria no longer apply
one is i don't enjoy it
anymore and thus the second
criterion
i'm no longer good enough if i
determine that for myself you have an
area in this company and that
is the core area  in my
business i think i can still be quite good at that
as long as that's the case and
i enjoy looking at the phone in the morning
and the first two guys or
they just seen before before we
started our podcast
a sports director called me or
a sporting manager of a
club and as long as it's still fun
to call him back right away which
one so on
you have to say I've
sometimes mentioned
European competitors here
again
I think he's somewhere in his sixties and he's
still doing the job  man is over
80 not more than than as a
competitor the name comes up again and
again but that's now  none of the competitors
the
treasures in ours
had even brought alaba from bavaria to
madrid well that's just
such a story but we
have to hang onto it for two hours now
the podcast is
free of charge david alaba wants to remember a lot of
real people and why  when the
family, especially the father, then
decided to switch to this consultant
, many in the inner circle know
that we also accompanied david alaba on a payment
and we
assume that we also had one or the other
conversation with real madrid in this
regard  and the father then
decided
on the home stretch to switch to pkv after all that's
always up to
you I know if he's also able
but please what do I want to be able to do that
then that will come beforehand so that
defeats in our  there is
no business even christians yes sometimes you get no
sometimes a player comes along and makes
a safe player that’s that that that
I don't call that a
defeat for me experience defeat personally
or have
you experienced one or the other in my life but in business
it's there for me I'm rational there
I'm totally rational and it was
n't like that that we're going to be short  before the
contract was signed it was
allowed to accompany players internationally my
colleague sascha brise traveled with his father
to many clubs all over europe
and held talks and i
think a year or so before the
player finally changed pini
zahavi changed and we have to explain the reasons
not known to this day but
that's part of it so i can't
go there and poach players away from other competitors
or if you are
dissatisfied then being in
the right place at the right
time and getting the player and
then I'm happy if you get players  you bring one of
our competitors that's
part of it that's the business all
right volker thank you very much
see  r had a lot of fun which also noticed
maybe my passion football
so as a hobby at least could
live out many thanks
this podcast is produced by
popstars
at mr